[Music]
good morning
it was absolutely spectacular weather
not humid
skies were clearer smoke is billowing
out of the building ap network news a
plane apparently has crashed into the
world trade center in new york we went
from a calm beautiful day to one in
which
our world changed dramatically
september 11 2001 was the worst
terrorist attack in us history now
experience the first 12 hours
surrounding the events
in a way the world has never seen
andy carr comes up behind me and says
america's under attack and i'm watching
the child read we needed to move the
president and get him out of there he
could be a sitting duck
there was a call that said angel's next
angel was the code word for air force
one
we worried someone in the president's
circle could try to take down air force
one
every plane had become a missile one of
the targets might well be the white
house all aircraft
possible mother got on the phone she
said we're outside milwaukee i said you
got to be kidding me what are you doing
there
she said you grounded our plane
in their own words she told me her plane
had been hijacked and the line went dead
it really hit home those at the heart of
power on that unforgettable day we did
everything we knew to do
but 3 000 people died on your watch it
just gnaws at you come together to
reveal what happened behind closed doors
she took the badge from her son's dead
body gave it to the president and said i
i want you to always remember
i remember the secret service screaming
take off your heels and run we never had
a crisis quite like this of course we
all were hurting we all were terrified
the first plane was an accident the
second one was an attack
and the third one was a declaration of
war
you